ويمكن توضيح بعض المفاهيم العشائريه
كالقبيله وهي المصطلح الاكبر من العشيره
التي تشكل جزءا من كيان القبيله وقد تحتوي
القبيله الواحده على خمس عشائر اما
العشيره فهي مجموعه من الافخاذ التي تضم
عددا كبيرا من الناس يجمعهم انحدار واحد
ولقب واحد
فتشوف النسيج الاجتماعي للعراق هو العشائر
النسيج الجيد واللي تعهد الحياه المدنيه
تختلف عن العشائريه بهذا الاتجاه يعني صح
يجوز يعرف خال اخو امه بس ما يطور الهذا
ما يطور العلاقه هسه مثلا لام يجي يصيح لي
خالي لانه يجوز واحد من بني اخذ عزاويه
مخلفه هو ولد عمه ولد عمه بس هو يصيح
الخارج خالي الواحد خالي الكل
فاكذا النسيج العراقي الاجتماعي العشائر
والعشيره في المجتمع العراقي تكوين
اجتماعي سياسي مبني على انظمه وقوانين
خاصه تعرف في الفرات الاوسط والجنوب
بالاعراف العشائريه
وللعشائر قوانين خاصه تحكم العلاقه فيما
بينها بفضل النزاعات والخلافات حول ملكيه
الاراضي او عند حدوث مشكله ما
نحن ما عندنا قانون عشائري ولا قضاء عندنا
عرف عشائر وهذا العرف متوارث من خلال
اجزاءنا وابائنا توارثنا العرف العشاري
ولحت هذه اللحظه نحن متماسكين بالعرف
الاعشاب